let's go back to the phones let's go to
aubry in cleveland ohio
what's up aubry hey john thanks for
taking my call
thanks for calling my husband and i had
our daughter
two weeks ago after she was born we sent
out her name and information that day
and immediately uh we got a text asking
us to change our name
her name from my parents
hold on number one congratulations on
having a baby everybody's healthy
everybody's good
yeah we're great congratulations big
time that's awesome
number two what you got a text saying
change the name please
yeah well it's because her
grandmother my mom's grandmother was
evil
and that was her first name which we
didn't know it was her first name
everyone called her
by her middle name but it was the same
as our daughters
and then the next day my parents called
and said that if we kept the name my mom
had too much trauma to even be near the
child and she didn't know how she
couldn't
hurt the child if she was around it oh
good lord god almighty
what yeah so my mom and my younger
sister now don't want a relationship
because i wasn't willing to change the
name
because i'm hurting my mom and so my
husband and i we want to know did we do
the right thing
how do we create boundaries or gain
closure from not having them in our
lives
and then how do i save the relationship
with my little sister
um aubry listen i need you to hear
something that's happening right now
there are very few moments of my life
when i am speechless
when i am just sitting there with my
mouth a gape
wondering what in the world is going on
on planet earth and you have
i told someone the other day i think
i've seen it all and you have just
dropped a new one on me
so congratulations aubry this is a big
day for
me as a person this should be a big day
for you so you and your husband should
go out and celebrate just the fact that
you shut me up for a second so way to go
um number one first and foremost
you can name your baby truck driving
binoculars for all i care
you can name your baby i i mean
you can name your baby mars i think
didn't elon musk name his baby like a
bunch of like
consonants and letters and symbols or
whatever dude
aubry you and your husband can name your
baby whatever you want
end of story closed close that fence
okay
number two what i've got to know what
evil means
was your grandma abusive was she a
murderer was she a witch like what what
was she what does that mean evil or she
just like
you know said mean things or something
what does evil mean
yeah i think what we've heard just from
the stories is that she was manipulative
and controlling
and sometimes emotionally abusive but we
didn't really hear a lot of stories
about her
just again if if my mom called me okay
so my daughter's name is josephine
um if my mom called me and said hey john
listen and by the way you don't send a
text with this type of
request you have a human conversation
so i my mom called me and said hey
listen you don't know this but your
great-grandma
was somebody who murdered children
that's just what she did
she had a hatchet and she liked to go
murder children and her name was
josephine
and we were trying to remove that name
from our family tree
then i would say good lord mom thank you
for telling me
and i would sit down with my wife and
we'd have that conversation
if my mom said hey i had a great grandma
and that lady was manipulative and mean
and i don't like that name you're not
allowed to have that and she sent that
to me in a text i would say
well the name of our child is josephine
that's the vr name
so that brings me to the second part
here's the deal you can't control
your mom you can't control your sister
and i hate that for you that
out of nowhere this type of boundary
violation has popped up but there's not
a lot you can do to control
that type of external manipulation
my guess aubrey tell me if i'm wrong
here is there's other cracks in that dam
is that fair yeah
tell me some other things that have made
you uncomfortable relationally with your
mom
in recent past or in the very past
um i got divorced before i married my
husband
the second time and she stopped
talking to me for two years over that
yep
and she came back yeah okay
what about give me another one before
that
um so i have there's four of us and
when my brother had his child out of my
back and then my sister
had his her child out of wedlock she
also stopped talking to them for a few
years
there you go i think it's a pattern of
behavior for her but
the whole her threatening to hurt a
child just we can't get over that
yeah and you should not get over that
hopefully you will never get over
somebody threatening to hurt your child
and moving forward you've got a mom who
uses her relationship as a weapon
right and the only way to deal with
something like that is completely
disengaged
and they don't get a role in your life
number two
somebody threatens to hurt your child
then that's when you let them know i'm
gonna
contact the police if i ever hear that
nonsense again you're not welcome around
my child
period end of story if in the future
which she will
she will come back because she will
recognize that that sort of weaponry
doesn't work with you
if she wants to take her relational ball
and go home in a huff and puff
like my four-year-old daughter does i'm
taking my doll and i'm leaving
she wants to do that she will recognize
in short order whether it's a year or
two years or four months or whatever
that that kind of nonsense doesn't work
with you that you and your husband
are tight and you have a great
relationship you're going to be a great
mom and you're moving forward together
and that that doesn't work that she will
come back and circle up and
at that point you're going to need to
revisit strongly and
very very directly aubry this idea of
you threatened my child
and i need to know what you meant by
that i need to make sure that there is
very clear boundaries between when you
are going to be with my child
and that you and or your husband will be
in that room in
any sort of hint at all about anything
it's called the police
period end of story i don't care if
she's your mom i don't care if she's
your sister i'll give you grandmother
care for whatever
right that's a no no one crosses that
beer year ever
as it comes to your sister tell me about
that relationship
it's actually pretty strong i mean i
took care of my sister
while my dad was in iraq and um
we we hang out quite a bit so i'm just
shocked
that she would take my mom's side and be
okay
she would that she's okay with changing
the name to just
make mom happy yeah i
those kind of relational dynamics
particularly with manipulative people
people are manipulative in that way like
your mom is being because it works
sometimes
and there may be some kind of big hook
small hook
giant hook sharp hook in your sister in
this
little season she's in and i wouldn't
lose a lot of sleep over that
my guess is she'll circle back because
she knows that you love her she knows
that you care about her
and she knows that you've been there for
her and you will continue to be there
for her
i would leave an open door with my
sister and let her know that hey i love
you
my husband and i are sticking to this
name but i love you
and i'd continue to reach out to her
with some regularity but
again at the end of the day as hurtful
as this is she can choose to not be in a
relationship with you she can choose to
distance herself and walk away from you
even over something as small and silly
as this
and when she does she does right and
that's going to hurt you and you'll need
to grieve that separation or that loss
with your husband or with a group of
friends because that's going to suck
but my guess is she's going to circle
back and probably
she's learned some of her relational
behavior from your mom right
and she learns that i can weaponize
myself and get people to do what i want
when i tell them that i'm just going to
disappear
people will jump sometimes and so that's
what she's got that's she's practicing
that on you
and i would keep strong on your
boundaries how's your new marriage how
do you like you like this guy
i love him he's my best friend he's
awesome
yeah do you guys have a good crew around
you do you have good friends you have
people who showed up to the hospital to
see this
beautiful new baby yeah they came over
afterwards
because the hospital wouldn't let him in
but yeah yeah covered nonsense
do you have a like a church group or a
softball group or some friends there in
your community
yes good so um i am big on family i am
big on reconciliation i'm also real big
on boundaries
and right now you guys have drawn drawn
the appropriate boundaries
and you have a group around you so
you're not isolated on a loan
um out on an island with this with this
awesome guy which would probably
wouldn't be so bad he sounds like a
great dude
um but man god bless you god bless you
aubrey
uh go forward and be strong keep those
connections with your friends and your
community
continue to nurture that relationship
and you've got a two week old beautiful
little baby
um man cherish every weird
uncomfortable second with that new baby
and
um when you get exhausted make sure that
that awesome husband of yours is there
to pick up the slack too you all work
together on that
congratulations moving forward i hate
that you didn't have
everyone rally around you to celebrate
this awesome moment
but it is what it is what it is thanks
for the call and congratulations you are
the first
i need to start keeping track of these
things man you're the first person to
completely stumped me for a second there
i liked it